[ Upbeat music playing ]
♪♪
-[ Chuckles ]
-Whoa.
-Wow.
[ Maraca shaking ]
Okay.
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
-[ Laughs ]
There she is. You got it.
♪♪
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Ben Stiller.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip
from "Severance."
This is a fantastic show.
Super specific, super unique.
And an idea that came to you
years ago.
-Yeah.
Dan Erikson,
who created the show,
wrote the script as a sample.
We got it five years ago,
and I read it
and I thought it was amazing.
And it took a few years to
get it going, but we finally --
We started to produce it
right before the pandemic,
about six months
before the pandemic.
So then we were about to
start shooting,
then we had to shut down.
So we've been on it
for like two and a half years.
-Every detail about it
seems perfect,
from the set design, we've been
talking about casting backstage.
Opening credits are amazing.
Did you --
When you first saw those,
did you just think,
"Oh, my God"?
-Yeah.
You know, I saw this guy
on Instagram called Extraweg
that had this -- he had this
weird animation of, like,
babies coming out of a brain
and, like, turning into jelly.
And I thought,
"This is amazing."
And so I reached out to him,
and he hadn't done
an opening credits sequence,
but it felt like his vibe
was right for the show.
So he worked with us
over the course of time
and like, you know, we're --
getting to know the scripts
and all that.
So it's been like a lot of time
to sort of like mount it in
the way that we wanted to do it.
And it's been fun
to have it come out
because we've been in the bubble
with it for so long.
-Yeah.
-And not knowing how people
would react to it, 'cause it is
kind of weird and specific.
-When you reached out to --
what was his name?
-Well, he's called Extraweg.
His name is Oliver Latta.
He's in Berlin.
-Gotcha.
How long did it take
to convince him you were you?
-[ Laughs ]
-Like, I would just think
a guy --
-Like a catfish sort of thing?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-No, no, no.
I mean, I set up a Zoom with him
so he could see me.
-Oh, so he saw your face.
Yeah, that's helpful.
You can't just reach out
and be like,
"Hey, this is American director
Ben Stiller."
[ Laughter ]
We were also --
You know, "Dannemora,"
which was so fantastic.
And I was watching this
and while I was watching it,
I was like,
"It's so cool that Ben did
something completely different,"
but there is really
like a prison element
to both these shows.
-Yeah.
-Did you know that
from the jump?
-No, I'm so dense it took me
about a year into shooting
because I thought,
"Oh, this is really different
than Dannemora."
We're doing this, like,
sci-fi weird thing
and, you know, it's got
a totally different feel.
And then about a year
into shooting,
I'm walking around the hallways
and I said,
"I feel like I'm in prison."
And all of a sudden I'm like,
"Wait a minute,
this is just like
that prison thing I did.
This is exactly the same.
I haven't done
anything different at all."
-[ Laughs ]
-But it is -- it is --
You know, you realize that
there's so many
different human elements
that are going on down there,
because they are down there.
They're not
technically prisoners,
but their life
doesn't exist outside of there.
-Yeah.
-I mean, they've had their
consciousness split.
There's a chip inside their head
so they don't remember who
they are when they go to work.
They don't remember what
happened when they leave work.
So it's an interesting concept.
-It's a great concept.
It's such a fun puzzle, and you
guys put so much care into it.
And I really enjoy
watching a show like this.
And I feel like,
obviously I'm not alone,
is it fun having
worked on something so long
to have people respond to it
and all of a sudden be like,
"Oh, we made
a thing people love"?
-Yeah, it's great. I mean,
it's such a nice feeling.
But there's also -- I've never
really been a part of a show
that has
that sort of interest in it,
where people are wondering
what's gonna happen
the next week
and, you know,
kind of a "Lost" type that --
I never watched "Lost," really.
But I know, you know, I know
what that kind of thing is.
So it's been fun to see
how people speculate
and have these theories.
But also the reality
is we finished it.
It's done, so people will
be like, "I hope he doesn't,"
you know, "I hope she's alive.
I hope this doesn't turn out
to be that they're real."
And I'm like,
"It already happened, I don't --
I really hope you like it,
because there's
nothing I can do about
what's coming on next week."
-Right.
It's not like "SNL,"
where it's like,
"I hope next week they do this."
Oh, it's too late.
-It's just
it's already baked in.
-And again, it must be so much
fun to do a show that's a hit.
We were talking backstage about
"The Ben Stiller Show" on Fox,
which won an Emmy.
-Yes.
-And --
-Not a hit, though.
-Not a hit.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I think we can speak to it
because --
-It's so funny, I went to see
Billy Joel the other night,
who was amazing.
And before every song that
we've all heard a million times,
he would say,
"This was not a hit,
this was not a hit, this was..."
because at the time,
they weren't.
But "The Ben Stiller Show"
was canceled
after, you know,
like 12 episodes.
-It won the Emmy
after it was canceled, right?
-Yeah, we'd been canceled
for nine months.
[ Laughter ]
-I think that speaks
to how a show endures,
that people got it so wrong.
-Yeah, no.
I mean, we were all shocked
and very happy, but it was.
-Did you walk up
and go "It wasn't a hit"?
[ Laughs ]
-I did something like that.
I did some stupid
young person's speech.
-Well, for anybody who --
If you finish "Severance,"
I think go back and watch
"The Ben Stiller Show,"
a very nice companion piece.
-Oh, perfect.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
-Great to see you, man.
-Ben Stiller.
A new episode of "Severance"
is available
this Friday on Apple TV+.